how you doing michael good i'm good how
are you doing thanks for being here
thank you for having me got a lot of
fans here people excited to see you
to see you and me
um now it's funny uh last time you were
on the show we were talking and you were
just about you were you were promoting
superbad right yeah and and you were
telling me that you were just about to
go to europe yeah and you were excited
because you know you you were curious to
see how superbad would be received yeah
over in europe and i'm just i never
heard what happened not well not well
what do you mean i mean i guess i think
it did okay but but when we were there
especially in italy it just felt like
people did not like the movie they
didn't like it in italy well i mean it's
hard for them to relate i think because
you know it's so much about getting
alcohol and like this quest for alcohol
which they i mean they drink when
they're like 5.
[Laughter]
what's the bigger deal
that's my sensitive portrayal
of an italian man i'm half italian my
father's from italy not that i'm
offended but um yeah
are you sure i hope or not uh
i'm making you a pizza bye michael
that is how he thought he said that to
me he does talk like that did that did
that come up at all when you were when
you were doing the promotion in in italy
yeah
all i know how to say in italian is my
father comes from sicily which is mio
papavi nadella sicilia
and um
during the q a that would get us out of
a slump somewhat like i would say that
and they would go ahead and go oh yeah
but it only worked like i tried it like
five times it was like an hour long q a
and it was going really poorly at a
certain point they probably think
something's wrong with you if you keep
saying my father is from sicily
[Applause]
you
i don't know leave me alone
i've got way for thin talent and an hour
to kill uh now
last time you were here you were telling
us that you had this weird experience
yeah you thought that your hotel room
was haunted yeah i was in san diego and
my speaker phone kept turning itself on
like it happened a few times and um the
night that i was on the show here
talking about it i told that story i
went back to my hotel and this is true
the same thing happened to me like seven
times in a row the speakerphone just
comes on by itself yeah in new york and
um i called the front desk and said does
this ever happen does did people ever
say that the speakerphone turns itself
on and the woman's exact words were no
never
so so you think that means there's a
ghost i don't know what it means but i i
don't want it to happen again
it's it's not like something that makes
me feel good i mean it's terrifying
i wouldn't think it would make you feel
good i was like oh
do you think it was the same ghost from
san diego that came to new york i don't
know to see the big city
[Laughter]
that makes it a little less scary um now
has your life would you say your life
has changed a lot since superbad came
out somewhat i mean yeah in subtle ways
um you know because the movie was such a
big success people really liked that
film yeah and so your audience from
arrested development grew yeah now more
and more people must know who you are is
that a good thing well the first night i
mean the weekend it came out i went to a
bar where i live in toronto and and it
was very strange like people you know
coming up and people are very aggressive
when they're drunk as you might know
and um actually i this this happened to
me a few months before the movie i
almost got beaten up by a guy for no
reason i know that sounds like
you know just my side of the story but
it's true
i was minding my own you're not you
don't seem like a guy that would be in a
bar like oh fighter no no
who wants a piece of michael said
it's not how you come across that's not
what i say no yeah no he just came up he
didn't know me i think he thought it was
someone else and he wanted to fight me
and then that was that was in june and
super bad came out in august the weekend
it came out i was in a bar and i saw
that same guy and he was sober and i'd
only ever met him once before when he
was trying to beat me up and he came up
to me and he's like hey michael hey
i didn't even realize you were an actor
you know he was talking to me and he was
like see do you go to los angeles a lot
and i went yeah once in a while for work
he goes i'd love to go with you sometime
what this is the second time i've met
him and he just wants to
go on a trip with me
[Laughter]
and the only other time was when he was
trying to beat me up
so are you seeing any more of this
person yeah he's my roommate now we
looked at that yeah
in los angeles
he's a sweet guy uh now uh you started
acting i mean you're young now but you
started acting when you were really
young yeah when i was about nine more
than half of my life now i guess right
yeah that's that's uh do the
math you challenge the crowd
do the math
then fight me what i said was true what
you you work in like you ever you worked
on a sitcom oh yeah i did the first kind
of big job i have had was on a sitcom
that was taped in front of an audience
and um it never aired but um we did
eight episodes
you made eight and they never showed
anything oh yeah we got cancelled but
yeah it was funny randy quaint played my
father he's a cool actor yeah it kind of
scared me from uh you know audiences i
mean
it's terrifying doing that in front of
an audience you know sitcom because
anything can happen one episode we were
taping i have i had like an older
brother on the show that was this
handsome actor brian science uh he's
handsome
and um
and um he was 19 i was about 13 at the
time
and um we're doing an episode i'm
talking to randy quaid who's my father
about girl troubles and i'm like you
know what do i do and he goes you know
some people just have the gift your
brother has the gift and i go why he's
not better looking than me and randy
quaid's line is oh you don't think so
then he rolls his eyes like that right
and while we were taping i go well why
he's not better looking than me and this
girl in the audience goes yeah he is
oh
that's not nice yeah i mean i hate it
when that happens the mentality of that
like okay i know this is not a real show
but i can't go on with it i can't sit
still for this i can't let them say that
yeah that's definitely not true uh well
let's talk about this film
nick and norah's infinite playlist and
uh this is a a good character for you
you've you've gone through this painful
breakup right yeah yeah it all takes
place in one day and i've just had my
heart broken by a girl
and uh well i don't want to give away
too much what's the clip we're gonna
show um this is me being
attacked by kat dennings who who plays
nora in the movie and we're just getting
to know each other in this night and um
we're having you know there's some
friction and tension and we end up
getting in a fight let's take a look at
this clip from nick and norah's infinite
playlist
can i just ask what did you see in her i
could floss with that girl this is your
friend that we're talking about okay
forget it i can't do this do what just
make a u-turn and take me back to ludlow
all right i'll find my own way perfect i
refuse to be the goody bag at your pity
party nick i have to yell it's not a
train station we're in a tiny car just
drive me off i will
[Music]
are you crazy
i don't know what i did to you to make
you so angry nothing you're just you're
ridiculous you don't even know me i know
you i know you're make i'm make you're
an emo punk band boy and you're obsessed
with triss they can make action figures
out of you drummer not included you know
it's funny that tris never mentioned you
considering what good friends you are
but she did mention some that was
completely jealous oh jealous yeah and
so now i think i know exactly who she
alright sweetheart you think you have
something
i am not jealous
that's the lowest yeah the throat punch
yeah
and you're driving the worst car in the
world what is that that's a hugo that's
a hugo yeah they had three of them you
were driving the crappiest car in that
movie uh nick and norah's infinite
playlist check it out it opens on friday
thank you michael uh please come back
absolutely we're always fun to talk to
you michael sarah we'll be right back
with comedian nate vargas stick around
[Applause]